someone told me today that you've been
married is this right it's your
anniversary it's 23 years
yeah it's 23 married it's amazing it's
exhausting I have no idea I've been
married I mean I'm not in that Club I'm
in the I think I'm in the 16 year I said
I think please having a 16 year club but
I'm in the 23 year club too I mean just
for making it that long and this way
like a some days it feels like heroism
other times it feels like complacency
okay when you met your husband you met
him first of all on a sprite commercial
yeah on an audition on an audition for a
commercial okay yeah no right away did
you see this guy and think that's the
guy no this is the most depressing
conversation his first pick-up line to
me he annoyed me straight out of the
gate and still does right that's okay he
knows it it's no secret there at all
right but his pickup line to me was you
look exactly like my girlfriend you have
a head shot so I could show her
that's a pickup line for him yeah and
then he took it home to his roommate and
said this is the girl I'm gonna marry oh
that's sweet or stalk those things go
either way so did the I mean so then you
start dating and how quickly did you
guys realize okay this is the real deal
um we were like good friends for a
couple months he thinks we were together
two weeks he thinks he just like
conquered that and had it and he did not
right it was a couple months right so
now in time he has he has sort of
changed the story that he met you and
right away it all happens he repeats the
same story over and over again right
what is that what is that do you go that
is that it's called delusion you know
it's why don't you guys repeat the same
stuff over and over you know my son is
now saying you told us that yeah and he
stated yes 12 and I'll say like I just
said I loved you
I don't know his dad does it he does it
he mocks his dad for but then he does it
too
yeah my wife does it yeah I will say you
know you've told me that four times now
that's all that because you haven't done
it very unreliable she keeps telling you
to like pull your pants up
what no no nothing like that but it is
like so what kind of story is that
and then my penis came out that's not a
story
oh it was a stress oh come on all right
that's what I'm always saying to my kids
you know what's weird though and I find
this would be I think this would be
strange is that you're both actors so he
obviously has to see you play love
scenes and you have to see him do that
are you comfortable with that are you
okay with it
yeah we've always had this odd kind of
you know like when I did keeping the
faith with Edward Norton and Ben Stiller
Edward Norton directed that movie and he
hired my husband to play this character
that was in an office building across
from my character's office building and
that character all he did was make out
with like four different chicks
mm-hmm and I think Edward did that too
like I thought he thought that was
hilarious
I hire my husband to do that I think
your husband did that yeah it's no it's
no secret so that would be yeah so
you're you're you would have to look at
your husband would you were you on set
for that make it no we're just trying to
like not have me show up on set that day
and I was like there's no way you're
keeping me from watching this being
films like I want to watch my husband
make out with all these chicks because I
thought it would be kind of humorous and
he we didn't tell him I was watching and
he got super embarrassed that I was
watching him because he thought he was
kind of like having this freedom to just
make out with all these chicks and not
worry about performance or what he
looked like it was totally watching yeah
and I was she had a video camera and I
filmed the whole thing yeah
if it's also it's in a movie so I know
but not yeah you saw him in the movie
and I took a video of him and that's how
I caught him
but the real the relatives at
Thanksgiving don't know it was in a
movie without the tape in my back pocket
you